good luck trying to make your connection
in El Paso Julio Rosas a senior reporter
from townhall.com joins us now live
from El Paso so paint the picture for us
it's very simple Jesse and it's the fact
that as you alluded here earlier this is
starting to look more and more like Skid
Row or any other U.S city that's had a
major homeless problem when I was here
last week there was around 80 people
between uh two blocks here by the
Greyhound bus station uh this week it's
around 150 people spread across about
five city blocks now there's people too
obviously some people behind me but
there's people in front of me and
there's people off to my left here and
that's just simply because uh there's
just been a massive surge in illegal
Crossings uh even despite the fact that
title 42 is still technically in place
it might go away next week it might be
extended yet again but for right now
there's clearly still a lot of people
trying to get into the country during
these four princesses are the illegal
immigrants that are behind you are they
waiting for a bus a flight what exactly
are they doing
it depends because some of these people
they don't have family or they don't
have any sponsors to help them get money
so that they can get a bus ticket or or
an airplane ticket and so uh they're
trying to figure out their next move the
others uh are waiting for for their
flights because you have to remember as
big as El Paso is
um it only has one airport that only has
one major uh bus station so you combine
that with uh the busy uh holiday season
and all the traveling that's happening
with just regular US citizens it does
create uh an acute supply problem and
also the prices have gone up
significantly uh for for both the go
coming and leaving El Paso so it really
just depends on what their situation is
yeah you want to be compassionate but at
the same time you want to be
thinking of the U.S citizens who live in
this country and pay taxes in this
country and deserve services and deserve
to be able to get out of the airport
without stepping over sleeping bag after
a sleeping bag all right great reporting
down there there and keep us posted
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else